what's some wild stories that happen out
there man oh man wild
like or tell me something gross crazy
you know i got them all
chicks trying to have sex to pay off
their bill is that true
oh yeah that happens i never did because
you're a handsome guy i'm sure you go in
there and there's the opportunity
for sex every now and then it's happened
uh i
you know i had a lady in seattle she was
she's good looking she you know
she it took forever for her to come to
the door i still remember it because she
was trying so hard you i mean
right you can tell when somebody's
coming on to you right yeah you know i'm
blind and all but
yeah i mean i'm a dude we miss most of
those signs all the time
a lot of times you miss them but so if
you don't miss them if a regular dude
doesn't miss them and
it's really becoming strong that's what
i realized dude this chick answered the
door
in a very thin white t-shirt okay
and that's it wow and that t-shirt was
just long enough oh yeah right and then
her stuff was upstairs so i'll show you
you know follow me so i followed her up
the stairs staring at her ass the whole
way up
so i could plunge her toilet in 30
seconds and fix it
and then she has me sit there for like
20 minutes i bet
while she sings karaoke to me on her
little private karaoke machine no way
still in this little t-shirt oh yeah
with great
big titties you can see every bit of
there
she didn't even need to be wearing the
t-shirt both of the tits you could see
them oh yeah yeah i mean
the the the shirt is so thin you can see
right through it oh yeah so
but the point was i knocked on the door
and i got there and i got no answer and
i knocked again i knocked again
it took her like five minutes to come to
the door and were you getting scared
what do you think she was doing
i was thinking she wasn't there i heard
her at first when she first came up i
heard her come to the door she looked
through the peephole
she saw i wasn't an old fat dude
probably you know because
you don't know what plumber's showing up
to your house that's true huh
so and then it was i kept knocking i'm
like so i called dispatch because at the
time
it was this roto you were gonna wrote it
yeah yeah at the time this was before
cell phone so all we had was next how oh
yeah so
yeah you know hey can you call this
customer that i'm here at her house and
i've knocked i
i hear that she's in there she ain't
answering oh yeah so they call him oh
okay she's coming to the door i'm like
cool thank you
and she answers the door like that i'm
like now i know what the [ __ ] she was
doing she went
got all ready and put her makeup on and
whatever else was she wearing sunglasses
or anything nope nope nope she was
slightly a little bit on the heavyset
side but
you know good looking and it's afternoon
is it morning it was morning probably 10
11 o'clock in the morning
cares what anybody's body's like in the
morning you know right uh south african
white chick
so that'll kind of get an accent oh yeah
it you know but still you know i'm on
the job
right you're professional are you
wearing a uniform oh yeah yeah and at
the time i was single and still
you don't [ __ ] where you eat no matter
what you just
it's only going to be clean [ __ ] there
you go or you don't [ __ ] where you clean
[ __ ] because that's
that's true too but i i don't know
something got instilled in me years ago
don't ever have anything to do with
anything with work like that right you
know what i mean yeah
don't [ __ ] your clients it's gonna yeah
yeah
and it's still a bad thing man once you
put sex into any work equation it all
becomes uncomfortable that's why me and
nick
is that why you guys don't get along
that's why we go to separate rooms and
touch ourselves
no we've never done anything like that
man and we never will nick and that's
why it's working so well yeah
so it works so well dude look i promise
you the second me and him
have any sexual interaction it's over
it is over and i think he would agree
yeah yeah so i moved to washington
no so the lady you're there you're in
the place oh i that was it
i i hate you know it's such a s it could
have been so
i'm karaoke music that's what i mean
what karaoke music oh she's singing like
love songs and stuff and trying to like
sell me her voice basically and you know
why was she saying that she used to do
music she considered and she was
totally into music and and she wanted me
to hear her sing she was trying to get
me to
nail her on the couch right there wow
and where was the uh
karaoke machine this was after
unstopping the toilet i had gone back
downstairs to write the invoice
i'm sitting on the couch she's next to
me on the couch oh yeah i got i've given
her the invoice she's got the checkbook
and instead of writing me the check so i
can go to my next job
she spends all this time singing trying
to
seduce me basically yeah and i'm trying
to be nice i'm trying to be
cordial i'm not trying and look ladies
what song i can't yeah
20 years man this is literally 20 years
ago i bet
15 years ago i i just can't remember was
it rap music no
no i i want to say it was like slow like
put your head on yeah so something you
know
something softer than that oh wow yeah
sexual healing
marvin gaye i think you got it wow
she she was she was pulling out all the
stops to try and i i had another lady
in the same town grab my junk right
come in and grab me and kiss me and i
had to literally i was married at that
time so i
you know he said hey well even if i
wasn't right get off me pay me my money
let me go right let me go
mostly i'd be so scared
you know we're in an age of lawsuits
yeah now we definitely are though but 15
years ago people i think we still were
and what if it don't work out say this
girl kisses me and i
i throw her on the floor and just ravage
her and we have a great time
yeah and then i don't call her back and
now she calls my company and says
rape me on the floor and or whatever you
know
don't even go down that road don't even
cross so yeah i mean in hindsight do you
ever fantasize about have having had a
romantic instance though about you know
obviously the the south african one kind
of stands out if if i could have gone
back now being single i you know i
probably could have taken a run at that
and had a good time
yeah and all would have been fine but
hey mate yeah
i don't think they say that yeah that's
true actually
i think i need a [ __ ] plumber in my
head
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so
far from my home
my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been